quelques notes de musique des bougies et
détournées de tequila offerte par la
maison ses habitants de le vivent ont
trouvé l'astuce pour réchauffer leur
soirée d'hiver alors que la ville est en
proie à des coupures de courant à
répétition depuis environ 2 mois une
épreuve difficile pour le propriétaire
du bar et les artistes qui s'y
produisent même s'ils font preuve de
résilience
quelle que soit la situation nous sommes
toujours de bonne humeur nous attendons
les inviter nous ne fermons pas les
portes les gens viennent avec leurs
guitare boivent de la tequila avec nous
la cuisine ne fonctionne pas très bien
mais personne ne reste affamé
je me suis déjà habituée aux coupures de
courant j'ai un haut-parleur qui
fonctionne avec des piles quoi qu'il
arrive qu'il y ait de l'électricité ou
pas je chante
dans les rues de le vivre c'est le
blackout l'Ukraine répare peu à peu ses
infrastructures énergétiques endommagées
volontairement par les frappes russes
mais le système est au bord de
l'effondrement
millions d'habitants survivent sans
chauffage sans lumière et parfois sans
eau sous des températures glaciales et
le recours aux bougies générateur et
autres appareils à gaz a provoqué de
nombreux incendies domestiques plusieurs
dizaines de personnes sont mortes depuis
le début des coupures de courant mais
les Ukrainiens n'ont pas d'autres choix
comme l'explique ce commerçant
nous utilisons des batteries externes
différentes lampes à LED et nous
avançant petit à petit après ça ne peut
que s'améliorer les gens viennent ils
achètent même sans électricité
des enquêteurs mandatés par l'ONU
examine actuellement l'impact des
attaques russes contre les
infrastructures énergétiques en Ukraine
afin de juger si elles peuvent être
assimilées à des crimes de guerre